herzlich willkommen bei unserer schönen
illustren männerrunde hier vorgänger
kollege der boss und christoph der pimp
überhaupt lage
ich glaube die frage wie ist die lage
ich glaube der kollege weiß heute mal
wie die lage ist und zwar exakt die lage
klären
ich hab das mal hier für dich genau
recherchiert wurde diese frage seit
jahren schloss es wäre einmal kleiner
sie heute in düsseldorf das sind die
koordinaten hier die ich aufgeschrieben
51 grad 13 minuten nördlicher breite 6
grad 47 minuten östliche breite das ist
unsere jetzige lage aber auch seine
basis in köln das hab ich ja auch die
koordinaten der lage in köln noch
aufgeschrieben 50 grad 56 minuten
nördlicher breite und 6 gerade 750
minuten restliche breite das ist die
lage auf das kannst du gerne das hat
meine wenigkeit erklärt fischer ist
natürlich immer nur das amen im gebet
sagt amen in der kirche oder die gräten
meinem fisch aber jetzt in dem fall
denke ich schon dass es ein guter gold
anwärter ist vom inhalt ob die platte
jetzt gold geht das kann ich natürlich
nicht sagen und auch nicht beeinflussen
da müssen die jungen herrschaften und
die jungen damen da draußen wirklich mal
in die läden stürmen über itunes über
amazon sich die platte bestellen
versuche auf jeden fall gold zugehen wie
das star wars roboter und das war
wirklich mal versuchen gold zu holen die
katharer klappt es leute unterstützt uns
dabei oder ihr kommt auf tour vorbei
könnte auch noch die cd kaufen
da wird ein persönliches spendenkonto
eingerichtet in meiner burberry jeans
muss einfach erst mal musst du musste
ich zum beispiel 20 kilo abnehmen
dann habe ich mich schön rucksack
gekauft unsere käppi dass ich mich
schief aufgesetzt dann weibliche
offiziere östrogene in die ecm damit die
stimmlage hoch geht und dann ging ich
teilweise echt als absoluter hit petto
freestyler von vereinzelten dann hast du
auch das wenigen österreichischen habe
ich meine freestyle skills trainiert bei
mir ich bin eher der free fight fixierte
rapper allerdings teilen nicht so aber
auf jeden fall weit da bin ich schon
freund zu und da schlage ich auch gerne
mal mit voller wucht wir einen linearen
dazwischen hatten wir natürlich immer
mal wieder den einen oder anderen
kontakt mit der ein oder mit der ein
oder anderen selben dame die dann von
uns gleichzeitig sexual penetriert
worden ist
zwischenzeitlich hatten uns auch den
namen double penetration gegeben anstatt
kollegah und farid bang und wollten
unter diesem synonym rappen haben
gedacht kommt sind dann wieder auf
unsere alten wurzeln zurück gegangen
weil zu dir zu dem double penetration
zeiten da muss ich auch ehrlich sagen da
wurde nicht nur mit der geschickt
sondern auch die ein oder andere
ledige frau die auch keine kinder mehr
hat oder euro was heißt keine kinder
mehr wie kleine kinder über überhaupt
keine kinder immer gemeinsam muss man
auf jeden fall
wir sind nicht wie der rest die sich
streiten vertragen die sich wieder diese
ganzen moves die man immer sieht in der
deutschen szene wir sind anders wir sind
wirklich anders als oder ich sehe das
genauso
also ich denke ich schon kollege und ich
in der konstellation wird man uns noch
häufiger sehen und werden wir auch in
der vergangenheit halt immer nach jpg
1er mensch und auch sehr sehr vielen
sachen gefächert und laufen sind uns
halt immer hier und da mal über den weg
gelaufen und ich denke nach so einem
großen release werden auf jeden fall
noch hier und da gemeinsam die ein oder
andere mutter von dem ein oder anderen
sprechgesang fertigten sexuell
penetrieren